in 1492 Christopher Columbus sailed the
ocean blue and he discovered America
discovered the world was in fact round
and he's a hero and that's why we get
the day off from work and school and get
to celebrate him every October so you've
probably heard this story maybe once or
twice but you've probably also seen
competing visions of Christopher
Columbus and his legacy some that aren't
so favorable in this video series I will
clear up misconceptions for example
Christopher Columbus did not discover
America and he didn't actually discover
that the world was round people already
knew that in about 600 AD with Aristotle
but hopefully with these facts and
explanations of the implications of
Christopher Columbus and his voyage that
you as the viewer and budding historian
can decide for yourself if you think
that Christopher Columbus was a hero so
we're gonna change this into a question
Christopher Columbus's voyage started
way before 1492 when he started
petitioning different European
governments for funding for his trip so
Christopher Columbus was actually an
Italian navigator and he asked the
Portuguese and then he asked the Spanish
and then when King Ferdinand and Queen
Isabella of Spain wouldn't give him the
money originally he even threatened to
go to France and ask for money from them
but eventually he ended up doing the
voyage under the Spanish crown and he
got together a crew of about 150 men in
three ships you probably know the names
of those they were the Nina Pinta and
Santa Maria there they are they don't
look very high-tech but they did have a
lot of help from new technology in
Europe making these brand-new ships and
they you know we're a little bit nicer
than they look in these drawings
Christopher Columbus set out for the
first voyage ever across the Atlantic so
why was he going across the Atlantic
this has to do with a lot of motivations
that you can read more about in the Khan
Academy article motivations for conquest
but I'll give you a general overview
here
little acronym that I like to go with is
God gold and glory so these were some of
Christopher Columbus's main motivations
and I would say was mostly about gold
and glory Christopher Columbus aimed to
find a new route to the West Indies so
the West Indies were somewhere you know
over here really if you're looking at
this map and Europeans had to travel by
land all the way down through the Middle
East to the West Indies over here along
that route
there were many middlemen that imposed
taxes and it was just a really really
hard route to navigate so Christopher
Columbus wanted to find a way that he
could go west to get to the east
Christopher Columbus knew the world was
round right he wanted to go like that
but he was the first person to prove
that it was Columbus and his men set out
in 1492 and they have enough food and
water to last them a year so this was an
unprecedented voyage everyone was really
excited and curious about what they
would find and it ended up taking them
five weeks so it was a five week voyage
and it certainly wasn't pretty
there were many times where the ship men
lost morale and lumbus himself had
doubts so he even made this promise to
the people on the ship he said the first
person to seal and we'll get a silk coat
and so this was a way that he increased
morale when things were looking really
rough but he was a very impressive
navigator and used the Stars and lots of
really impressive scientific measurement
to arrive in the Bahamas the Bahamas are
part of an island group called the West
Indies and why are they called the West
Indies because Christopher Columbus
thought that he had arrived in the
Indies which are a Island group in
Southeast Asia
so geographers then named the West
Indies West has to distinguish them from
the islands that Christopher Columbus
thought that he had in fact arrived on I
know kind of funny to think about now
because they are just so far away but
Christopher Columbus was determined that
he had in fact arrived in the East
Indies so that's where the named Indians
came from the native people were not
related to or descendents from Indians
anyway Christopher Columbus was just
determined that China was just a little
bit north of them and that they had
successfully found this new trade route
to give you a sense of where Christopher
Columbus ended up can check out this map
so he came from Spain and first landed
here in the Bahamas so he named it son
Salvador that was the first place that
they stopped and in San Salvador they
encountered the Taino people so the
kalos were historically a very friendly
people they were very welcoming to
Christopher Columbus and his men and
Christopher Columbus actually wrote this
all down in his journal so a lot of the
records that historians reference and
argue a fair amount about come from both
Columbus's Journal and his Provence as a
medic though these were literally proof
of merit in English and so Christopher
Columbus had to write back to the
Spanish crown to make sure that he was
actually making progress on his mission
that he was in fact finding a new trade
route and increasing capital for the
Spanish crown where else they would stop
funding him so there's a lot written
about his voyage between this journal
and between these official documents and
within those documents you can see that
Christopher Columbus and his people had
intentions of conquering and colonizing
the Taino people Christopher Columbus
writes they were very well built with
very handsome bodies and very good faces
they do not carry arms or know them they
should be good servants later on he
writes about the Taino people who were
historically jewelry traders and helped
them a lot with finding different
resources and gold and silver he writes
I could conquer the whole of them with
50 men these sorts of quotes from
Columbus Journal provide evidence to
historians that Columbus's violence
against Taino people was premeditated
and planned so this photo down here
depicts the Taino people welcoming the
spaniards and this image depicts the
traditional Taino culture you can see
the jewelry which Christopher Columbus
writes extensively about
lots of gold jewelry he found it very
beautiful he was met by these friendly
people but he did have intentions of
colonizing them and turning them into
servants and slaves which he then did so
when he returned to Spain 25:10 OHS got
on the ship with him back but only seven
survived and so this began the practice
of forcing the Tainos into servitude
which would increase over the next ten
to fifteen years during which
Christopher Columbus would come back and
forth to the Caribbean ultimately
Christopher Columbus made four voyages
so first one was in 1492 up here but
then there were three more voyages over
the next couple years and over the
course of these three voyages the Taino
people were decimated by violence and
disease so between the forced servitude
and the mutilation that the colonizers
would practice they would actually cut
off the Tainos limbs or hands if they
refused to do work for them disease
really was what killed the most Native
Americans at the time on the ships the
colonizers would bring with them yes
weapons but most notably microbes that
the Taino people were not accustomed to
fighting off when they would come into
contact with these new diseases the
Native Americans were killed in the
masses so over the course of Christopher
Columbus's colonization of the Caribbean
he ended up going to I'll scroll up and
show you a little bit more on the map he
ended up going to San Salvador that was
the first stop then to Cuba and then to
espanol ax which is the modern-day
Dominican Republic and Haiti and here in
all these places Christopher Columbus's
men set up different colonies and slowly
as Christopher Columbus kind of went
back and forth to Spain the colonies
rebelled against him by his third voyage
Columbus
ultimately gets removed completely from
this colonization project because he
proved such an awful leader and he
really had violent tendencies towards
the Taino people so in the next video
I'll talk a little bit more about the
implications of the contact with the new
world and about how Christopher Columbus
has become such a controversial figure
in American memory and American
celebration